JACQUI: INTERESTING DEVELOPS.
THANK YOU.
GIFF: JOINING ME NOW, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMITTEE HAS FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE, NICHOLS AND SERVES
ASSISTANT BEFORE THE HOUSE GOP,
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME ON THIS SATURDAY.
YOU HEARD OUR REPORTER, DAVID AT
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE LATEST
ABOUT THE E-MAILS.
LET ME GET YOUR REACTION TO THAT
THAT.
>> AS I WAS GOING THROUGH SOME
OF THE REPORTING ON THIS ISSUE,
I’VE NOTICED THE ACTUAL PARTS TO
TALK ABOUT IN CONNECTION TO THE
LAB HAS BEEN REDACTED SO FIRST,
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT WAS IN THE
REDACTED E-MAIL THAT HE SENT AS
IT RELATES TO WUHAN.
NOW HE SEEMS TO BE CHANGING TO
CALLING FOR A FORMAL
INVESTIGATION AND WE NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LAB RECORDS
AND WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE
INDIVIDUALS IN 2019 WERE AT THE
LAB, WE NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE WE SET DISPLAYS
SYMPTOMS OF COVID AND IT’S
SOMETHING THAT WE’VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR FORMAL
INVESTIGATION MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON CORONAVIRUS.
IT SHOCKING FOR DEMOCRATS HAVE
NOT YET BROUGHT FORTH PANEL TO
HAVE A REAL DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS AND THE OTHER THING IS,
AMERICA SHOULD BE LEADING THE
WAY.
WE MUST BE ADVOCATING FOR
ANSWERS OF THE COMMUNIST PARTY.
THAT IN ITSELF, THE FACT THAT 4
MILLION PEOPLE DIED, 600,000 IN
THE U.S., A GLOBAL COMMUNITY
DEMANDING ANSWERS AND WE SHOULD
BE HOLDING FUNDING FROM THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION AND
GET SERIOUS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
AND HOLDING THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY ACCOUNTABLE.
GIFF: A LOT OF QUESTIONS WHETHER
WE MIGHT GET THOSE ANSWERS FROM
CHINA DO YOU ANTICIPATE GETTING
TESTIMONY FROM DOCTOR FAUCI ON
THE HILL?
>> WE SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
BRINGING HIM IN, WE’VE ALREADY
WRITTEN TO SPEAKER PELOSI,
DEMANDING THAT SHE CALLS A
HEARING ON THIS ISSUE, BOTH THE
COVERED SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL AS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, WE MUST
INVESTIGATE THIS FURTHER, WE
SHOULD BE QUESTIONING DOCTOR
FAUCI AND THE CEO OF THOSE WHO
PROVIDED GRANTS TO THE WUHAN LAB
LAB, FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT WENT
OVER THERE, WE SHOULD BE DOING
WHATEVER WE CAN AS AMERICAN
OFFICIALS TO GET ANSWERS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
GIFF: SPEAKING OF DOING ENOUGH,
I WANT TO SWITCH GEARS A BIT, WE
GOT THE FRIDAY JOBS REPORT
YESTERDAY AND THE CHAIRMAN
PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT,
APPLAUDING THE JOBS REPORT AND
TAKING AIM SPECIFICALLY AS
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
LIKE YOURSELF, HERE’S THE
STATEMENTS THE CHAIR PUT OUT
SAYING AS EACH DAY PASSES IT
BECOMES MORE CLEAR CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS MADE A CALLOUS
DECISION TO TURN THEIR BACKS ON
STRUGGLING FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES WHEN THEY NEEDED HELP
THE MOST.
THAT’S FROM HER DIRECTLY.
REPUBLICANS WERE NOT ADVANCING
THE PRESIDENT’S AGENDA.
>> JOE BIDEN’S WORDS, THAT IS.
I’LL SAY IF ANYTHING, THE
DEMOCRATS TO OUR FULL RECOVERY,
100 MILLION AMERICANS ON THE
SIDELINES WHILE SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE DESPERATE TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE
THEY DECIDED TO GIVE INDIVIDUALS
MORE MONEY THAN SUPPORT THEIR
WORKPLACE.
THAT IS IRRESPONSIBLE AND
FRANKLY ONCE THE MANDATES AND
RESTRICTIONS LIKE GOVERNOR, PUT
IN PLACE WERE LIFTED, WE KNEW
JOBS WOULD COME BACK BUT DESPITE
CREDIT FOR THAT, FLIPPING ON THE
LIGHT SWITCH, IT’S DISINGENUOUS.
OF COURSE WE ALWAYS WANTED TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES AND
THOSE SUFFERING BUT THAT’S NOT
WHAT THIS PACKAGE IS, THEY PUT
IN ALL SORTS OF ADDITIONAL
SPENDING IS GOING TO HURT OUR
NATION AND IS ALREADY HURTING US
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LACK OF
LABOR AVAILABLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET
MARKET, THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS
INTERRUPTED AND THE COST OF
GOODS ARE GOING UP, INFLATION.
EVERYTHING IS GOING UP AND THE
RESULTS OF THE POLICIES PUT IN
PLACE BY DEMOCRATS.
GIFF: WE ARE OUT OF TIME, WE’VE
GOT TO LEAVE IT THERE.
A QUICK SHORT ANSWER, THE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE BEING INSTALLED
BUT CONTINUE ON INFRASTRUCTURE,
DO YOU THINK IT WILL BE RELEASED
NEXT WEEK?
>> I’M STILL HOPEFUL.
THEY ARE TAKING UP A BILL
WEDNESDAY, AS LONG AS WE FOCUS
ON REAL INFRASTRUCTURE, WE CAN
HAVE A DEAL.